our pal flekas talks one of his
journalists
just
caught
one of the most disturbing things i've
seen
in
a few weeks you want to know what the
liberal empire is selling they go to
this dallas gay bar
and they go to an event drag the kids to
pride
drag the kids to pride that doesn't
sound great
it's a show at
mr mr barr
billed as a family-friendly version of
the bar's regular champagne drag lunch
here's what they saw
how do you think the event went today
i think it was amazing i never get to
like perform in front of children like
performing in front of children i have
like six other younger siblings so it
was it was very emotional i loved it it
was probably one of the best shows i've
ever done what do you say to the
conservative parents that wouldn't bring
their children to an event like this
why here's the thing i don't think that
there is any kind of issue with exposing
children to this because
especially
if you if your child is in the community
or you may think they are i just think
that drag is educational do you think
that exposing children to drag will lead
children to do drag in the future in the
long run
not if they don't want to do drag i'm a
gay man and i don't want to do drag
so i don't think no absolutely not if
not grooming is not
you will be what you're what you are
we're not going to turn you into
something else because you come and see
this event
this video is so enlightening one
obviously this is freakish and perverse
and horrible and under no circumstances
should
should drag queens be allowed to jiggle
for kids you heard how creepy that guy
was at the top because i never get to to
dance around for kids this is really
great i love dancing around for kids in
my high heels and my this guy should be
arrested for doing this so
you know the video serves that purpose
too but it's so
telling about the
about the
hidden agenda here the not-so-hidden
agenda here because
the the little group at the end of the
of the people wearing the beto shirts
who just were customers at this bar who
were just talking about the show they
give one answer
to the question of what this means for
kids but the drag queen gives a totally
different answer
you saw they was asked so you really
think kids should be at this thing and
the drag queen he says oh yeah i think
drag is educational
and then
the the people in the beto shirts at the
end they say you really think kids
should be at this thing they say oh yeah
it's no big deal they're not being
indoctrinated they're not being educated
no it's
that guy he says no look it's not going
to make kids more inclined to do drag
no look i'm a gay guy and i don't want
to do drag and so kids are going to be
what they're going to be kids are going
to be who they are that woman there she
says no kids are they are what they are
and they never
change at all well those are totally
contradictory views of education of
human nature of the mind of the soul
the the drag queen is saying you become
something
you you start out one way but then
through education you become something
else education shapes your desires
education shapes your interests
education shapes your beliefs
and then the the
ridiculous group of people at the end in
the beta shirt they say nah education
doesn't do any of that you're just born
a certain way and you never change at
all ever you don't change your beliefs
you don't change your desires you don't
change your interests you don't change
anything you just nothing affects you
who's right obviously the drag queen is
right here obviously
not just drag shows
are educational but
all of culture is educational and all of
these lessons and all of these
instructions if if they weren't we
wouldn't send kids to school if we
weren't we wouldn't learn anything if if
they weren't educational if they if they
weren't another way of saying that is
indoctrinating if they weren't formative
in shaping people's views especially
little kids whose brains are so
malleable if they weren't
accomplishing that
in the drag shows then the left wouldn't
be promoting them the reason that the
libs are pushing for younger and younger
people and younger and younger kids to
go to pride parades to go to drag shows
to go to gay bars to watch men jiggle
around the reason they're pushing for
this is because it is formative is
because it shapes their minds they are
telling us this they are telling us this
in their own words and so they cannot
well they can but they it won't make any
sense and it's obviously disingenuous
they cannot simultaneously tell us that
the drag shows are not doing any of that
that the pride parades are not doing any
of that
we have to we have to we're not
indoctrinating the kids in
radical sexual ideologies and it's good
that we are
that's the argument they're making the
washington post is trying to make sense
of this they it was one of the funniest
articles i have read in a mainstream
paper in a very very long time headline
gender identity lessons banned in some
schools
are rising in others
and here is the the real money line
here's the
thesis of the of the column or of the
news article rather in florida and
several other states
educators are restricted in teaching
about gender identity but elsewhere
teachers are embracing the topic as the
number of transgender and gender
non-binary children rises
and i
i love this line because you might not
catch it if you're just reading it
quickly okay dude all right there's
different schools or disagreeing on you
but i love the way they frame it here in
florida and certain other states that
the conservatives are tamping down on
transiting the kids
but in other schools teachers are
embracing this topic
as the number of children who are
getting trans rises
you think those two things might have
something to do with one another it's
just so strange
it's i can't can you believe these
conservatives they don't want to
we the number of transgender children is
rising so why don't they want to teach
lessons where they encourage kids to
become transgender it's so weird
maybe because maybe because the lessons
are impelling people to become
transgender it reminds me of this of
this article by fox butterfield in the
new york times this is a famous headline
in the new york times they say
despite drop in crime
an increase in inmates
despite
crime falling the prisons keep filling
despite i don't know that despite means
what you think it means actually maybe
there's a connection here it's a strange
social phenomenon
that the crime rate continues to fall
even though we keep putting all the
criminals in prison like isn't that so
weird
no it's it it's only weird it's only
difficult to understand if you are so
taken with a radical ideology that you
can't see
plain realities right before your very
eyes
i'm so glad that the washington post
i'm so glad that that drag queen at that
bar in dallas i'm so glad that some of
the libs at least
are beginning to admit
that we were right all along arby you
know how much i hate to say i told you
so
you know how much i hate to take out my
nostradamus had my crystal ball and
predict the future
but they're telling us we were right
they're saying yeah we are grooming them
at the very least we're grooming them
intellectually at the very least we're
grooming them in their moral sense
to become accustomed to drag shows to i
mean at this show you had little kids
putting dollar bills in the thongs of
these creeps
this is
overtly explicitly sexual stuff
they say yeah no but it's all fun it's
just to teach tolerance maybe we
shouldn't tolerate that or we're going
to tolerate everything no
the libs certainly don't tolerate
everything they in fact
as we all know i almost don't even want
to say that's become cliche at this
point they're extremely intolerant of
all the normal good traditional stuff
that we've ever had in this country
they're intolerant of the american flag
in some cases they protest the
star-spangled banner so it's not a
question of being more tolerant or being
less tolerant
moreover though sometimes you'll hear
conservatives say we're the really
tolerant ones we're the real liberals
i'm a conservative because i'm a liberal
because i'm so tolerant i think you
should be able to say and do whatever
you want no that's not true either we
are also not the totally tolerant ones
nobody is totally tolerant nobody really
believes that people should be able to
say and do whatever they want whenever
they want to do it no that isn't true
at least i don't
i don't i don't want to tolerate the
drag show for kids i think that should
be shut down and the people who i think
there should be a law passed against it
and when people break that law i think
they should go to prison for a very long
time
call me intolerant
i call me
michael you're just not open-minded
enough i guess i'm not some people it
seems are so open-minded that their
brains have fallen out
no we we don't we're we're not totally
open and totally liberal and totally no
every culture has standards
i'm glad you like that clip now ding
ring slam like
subscribe ping i don't whatever you
gotta do subscribe get the notifications
to the michael knowles show head on over
also to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe there leave a five
star review please we will see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]